this summer  excitement is everywhere  baby  it's summertime baby we both have good  things going on right now  one of us got laid last night i have i  have i have genital herpes did you know  about this  stop rewind  unbelievable  somebody put a bag of drugs inside me  don't freak it out  all this knowledge  you can unlock secrets that go beyond  our universe  i'm not even sure that mankind is ready  for it  it's like all things that make me human  are fading away  something is coming something you've  never faced before  everything that happens now  is in your hands  you'll need a new weapon for this war  now you know where i get my dramatic  flare  come on  so  do  you